hold onto your hats true believers while
Marvel studio space for is pretty much
set in stone and phase five is only
beginning to take shape the rumor mill
has turned out an eye popper the studio
is reportedly prepping an Avengers vs.
x-men movie possibly for Phase six the
report comes from our friends that we
got this covered who we know don't
always nail it when it comes to the
Marvel pipeline but that hasn't stopped
them from making this bold claim about
the future of the MCU citing inside
sources the publication put forth a
surprising number of details about the
alleged Avengers vs. x-men project
according to these sources the proposed
picture would come down the pike well
after the x-men have been introduced
into the MCU which is not expected to
happen for two years or more it would
involve different Avengers from the ones
that we all know and love which squares
with comments made by Marvel head honcho
Kevin Feige to MTV News back in June
Mikey said at the time the New Avengers
will be a very different team than we've
seen before
that's what endgame was all about it
will be a very different incarnation of
the team with some people you've already
met and some people you haven't met yet
according to W GTC sources the team that
Marvel has in mind fits that description
to a tee black panther Scarlet Witch and
assuming that Sony and Marvel eventually
get around to ironing out their
differences spider-man could all be on
board as well as the Jane Foster version
of Thor who is set to make her debut in
2022 s Thor love and thunder also up for
spots on the team see movie use Schank
chief whose solo feature shang-chi and
the legend of the ten rings drops in
February 2021 and rehearsal ah Ali's
Blade whose solo movie is thought to be
scaring up phase 5 even more intriguing
Lee the flick is said to be taking the
inspiration for its plot from a
mind-blowing Marvel storyline House of M
the 2005 crossover events penned by
comics legend Brian Michael Bendis
mostly took place in an alternate
reality created by Scarlet Witch after
she suffered a mental breakdown but most
notably Wanda also used her reality
altering abilities to depower virtually
every mutant on earth not in the
alternate reality but in the actual
Marvel youth the events of house of M
had a lasting effect on the Marvel
Universe and elements of the story led
into the 2012 Avengers vs. x-men
crossover also co-written by Bendis
obviously a good number of tweaks would
have to be made
to adapt the story to the screen but
this is nothing new for Marvel Captain
America Civil War took a ton of
liberties with the 2006-2007 event from
which it took its title just as the
one-two punch of Avengers infinity war
and Avengers endgame did with 1991's
Infinity Gauntlet limited series while
the news of a potential Avengers vs.
x-men movie might sound like a whole lot
of wishful thinking it's worth
mentioning that the very same sources
that supplied W GTC with the Intel have
been right on the money with their
Marvel rumor mongering on multiple
occasions it had previously leaked that
the real Mandarin would be the villain
of shang-chi and the ten rings that the
post-credits scene in The Avengers end
game re-release would Center on the Hulk
and that iconic Marvel baddie the
taskmaster would be the primary
antagonist of next year's Black Widow
all of these reports turned out to be
accurate so while they may be wrong
sometimes these folks do seem to have
managed to sneak a few top-secret files
out of Marvel Studios offices under
their trench coats we may not yet know
exactly how mighty Marvel will approach
folding the x-men into the MCU or how
its tape will differ from the
long-running Fox Studios x-men film
series but we're going to go ahead and
state the obvious an Avengers vs. x-men
flick has the potential to be nothing
short of epic if we ever do get a formal
announcement the force of fans heads all
around the world exploding will register
on the Richter scale obviously Marvel
loves to keep details about its upcoming
films and television series close to the
vest meaning that even if Avengers vs.
x-men is being actively developed we're
not going to hear anything official
about it for a long long time they can
threaten me all they want Joss I'll
never talk about you but you better
believe that we'll be keeping our eyes
peeled for all the latest rumors and
leaks check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about the Marvel Cinematic Universe are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you